more than a dozen corporations including
Delta Airlines Hertz and the First
National Bank of Omaha say they're
ending NRA member discounts and other
perks in the wake of the school shooting
in a statement the NRA calls that a
shameful display of political and civic
cowardice Axios reports companies are
increasingly stepping up on social
issues when government has been
reluctant or gridlock Mike Allen and Jim
VandeHei are the co-founders of Axios
and there was with us this morning good
morning gentlemen Jim let me ask you
this question about it the NRA
there are some times when corporations
are ahead of politicians and that pulls
the politicians along with them there's
some times when corporations react to
pressure that's different than the kind
of pressure that operates on politicians
which is it at play here with the NRA I
think there's two things that are
hitting a company simultaneously that
are really reshaping our relationship
with with the companies and the
companies that we work for one is social
media I mean people can instantly put
pressure on companies to make big
decisions about their products to is and
I see this even a taxi us where the
Millennial workforce has a different
expert expectation of us as employers
they expect you to take a stand they
expect you to have opinions they expect
you to stand for something bigger than
just profit and companies are feeling
this and you saw this with the Muslim
band you saw it with immigration you saw
it with global warming and now you're
seeing it with guns where companies like
Blackstone over the weekend Bank of
America over the weekend are saying
listen we're gonna take a look at our
clients relationships with gun
manufacturers this never would have
happened five or ten when I was coming
up you didn't even challenge the company
boss you might have thought he or she
was wrong but you wouldn't speak out
about it certainly so publicly Mike no
that's right it's a lot harder now to be
a CEO because these issues that Jim is
talking about it and this includes me
too this includes LGBT discrimination
and this includes immigration like all
of those it used to be risky for a brand
or a company to talk about it now they
have to and it's funny this is partly a
trump effect just in the last year
there's been senators have changed from
pulling back to now you have to speak up
but that's because purchasers make their
decisions every day about whether to fly
Delta or not fly Delta but voters are
different in the way they behave if you
want to punish a lawmaker you have to
wait all the way to know
and in this case you have a calcified
group supporting second Amendment rights
they are they believe in them very
strongly so you have a pushback whereas
with consumer products you don't really
have a pushback so in terms of the way
this affects on lawmakers isn't it going
to be a little bit different you're
right you it for all the people who want
change in the wake of the shooting it
has to be in voting listen since a 1994
election the reason that Republicans and
a lot of Democrats by the way never
challenged the NRA is because they
believe that it's political suicide to
do so if Millennials turnout if voters
who are outraged turnout and suddenly
you see members of Congress losing
because of the gun issue it won't just
change it will change like that it'll
change instantly because lawmakers
respond to incentives and the incentive
is for them as I want to keep my job if
you lose your job because of it the game
changes on a debate that is otherwise
been defined differently for thirty
years I was talking to a lawmaker this
weekend who pointed out something I
hadn't thought of your freedom writer is
gonna be a voter in 2020 right and
they're starting to realize that there's
a big wave coming up and just as their
consumer behavior is different they also
are a lot more likely to have their own
opinions than mirror their folks or
mirror some of the other influencers
that young voters had in the past more
Millennials than baby boomers the
president said that he's going to talk
about this again today with the nation's
governors Congress comes back to work
after a long break do you expect
anything to happen listen it could have
listened the this president more than
anyone he does have a super power he is
this ability to get Republicans to do
things that we always thought they
wouldn't do we saw it play out on
deficits we saw a play out and how
Republicans view the FBI so if he said
listen we're gonna do something we're
really gonna raise the age we're really
gonna toughen background checks we're
really going to and even go after the
assault weapon ban if he ever wanted to
do it he could do it I don't think he
will because his cues are always he
muses in public about what he talks
about in private and when he talks in
public he's talking about arming
teachers like that's the thing that has
him most amped up right now I don't
think anybody thinks that that's the
solution and it certainly is not a
pathway to a bipartisan compromise to
get significant gun legislation well you
have to use his super power to get his
personal pilot now to be head of the FAA
which is something that he's not
throwing out there it's just pilot
qualified number one so this is the
pilot who flew Trump Force One during
the campaign John Dunkin a great name
and we were talking in the green room
like if we became president like like we
went our friends to a bunch of jobs
somebody in the Axios story saying this
is like on Seinfeld
when Kramer uses his caddy as a jury
consultant this is the president United
States has put forward
yes personal pilot to run the FAA like
that's not like we joke about it it's
not a joke is it a massive part of the
bureaucracy that regulates what happens
in the air and this is goes to the heart
of how Donald Trump does run the
presidency like a family business he's
got his son-in-law sitting there making
big decisions when he can't clear the
background check to be able to get
security clearance to have access to the
most sensitive intelligence daughter
Jared Kushner he's got his daughter
Ivanka intimately involved in tons of
public policy we so many days were like
how we laugh and laugh but this isn't
normal it's not normal to have this many
family members this intertwined in the
operation of the White House for the
obvious reasons when it happens it just
presents conflicts of interest there's a
reason chief of staff Kelley is outraged
by this doesn't really want the kids
there because it just makes life more
complicated for the people who are there
trying to do their jobs and not feel
like the deck is stacked because they're
not part of the family circle but this
is how drum has run his business for
decades mm-hmm all right and it's a
pilot qualified that's what I'm curious
about to run the FAA that's okay and
Mike Allen Trump used to say that he
liked his plane better than Air Force
one I think I remember that yeah I think
here's to my calendar Jim Bend I thank
you very much thanks for joining us at
the table